well hello miss Tamar live from
quarantine quarantine hair and makeup
job darling well she did a good job oh
why thank you I try you know good shirts
for my zoo meetings and go right back to
my couch
you've all also figured out how to add a
five hundred and first job to your list
of 500 jobs in this time with this new
show to catch a beautician that's coming
to the TV screen girl you got a hole in
your head Tamar Braxton and Johnny
Wright are here to bust bad dude all
right tell me how you got involved in
this kind of crazy project yeah the
crazy prat project that I'm most proud
of so given that I've had a lot of
hairdos over the years and also hair
catastrophes over the years and so I
mean Michelle just workin to like my
favorite thing to do talk about here
talk about people's problems and trying
to help them fix it when you've had
every hairstyle even been a couple years
ago you shaved it all off and it was my
best hairstyle and yes I really want to
go back to it because right now I'm an
in-between stage and my hair is a mess
under the wigs and ponytails and stuff
so I really don't know what to do with
my own hair and I really liked that kind
of independence you know what I mean
this is all me except me and it was
great and so I kind of want to go back
to it well I feel like that moment also
came at that turning point in your life
it's been like three years since the
separation the split what have you
learned about yourself in the last three
years that you didn't know about
yourself wow you know that I I'm one of
those women just like all the women in
America that I run into is that you know
we never give up we do whatever it takes
especially when you're thrown into the
position where you're single mom it's
like everything is hard but nothing is
too hard we figure it out and so I'm
just really happy to be a part of that
women empowerment in that crew and not
even just women anymore it's meant to
you know that's thrown in that position
and it just goes to show you how
resilient we all are when you have to
figure it out we figure it out oh yes we
do how does co-parenting
work in quarantine at first you know
co-parenting was very difficult because
you know I think the whole country was
afraid we didn't know if it was safe to
go outside and you know what what was
saving what wasn't so he was here for me
for you know the first month and now
it's it's great you know lo gonna go to
his dad's house every weekend or every
other weekend or will switch off each
week whenever Logan gets tired of each
pairing
how are things for you and Vince now
that it's in the rearview mirror the
divorce is finally finalized after all
those years of trying to get a finalized
write and not even just that get all the
years of trying to figure out where we
sit right because for 16 years but we've
been together I've been best friends and
I think we had to revert back to is
remembering that we were friends first
and it took a little while especially
now with David in the mix things you
know but we're in a really really good
place you know we've realized it's not
about us it's not about our feelings
it's not about what happened you know
it's about Logan and it's about us
setting the best example for him and
being there and so that's the choice we
made but you have to make that choice
how did you come to the place where you
realize that was there any specific
moment that sticks out like the turning
point or was it just over time well I
came from divorced parents so you know
right when it happened put my kid in
counseling enough people might disagree
because he was so young but I thought it
was the best thing for him just because
sometimes when you're that young or when
you're when you come from a divorced
parent you don't know who to talk to who
which parent to trust or whatever you
know you just don't even thrown into
this position and we just sat around the
counselor we don't one day and she was
like you guys might try to want to get
him wrong for your kids and then that
that is when we made a decision it's
about him and I love it how is Logan
adapting to his new normal so I found
out I'm raising myself Logan is of the
male version of me which is you know I
mean I shouldn't be surprised but I am
surprised he has a huge personality he's
hilarious is really really small
and he's like the greatest my saying
this about myself is the greatest kid
ever you know so cool he's the only
child so he looks to me to play all the
time but and that's a lot uh but um you
know I think we split time between Sonic
the Hedgehog and Real Housewives a bit
man okay good balance thing last time we
spoke I think you had changed your mind
about wanting more kids you went from
one-and-done
to like wanting a full braxton sized
brood where do we stand today I used to
go on that place I'm crossing my fingers
hoping I'll get lucky and I really
really want more kids and being in this
quarantine is reminding me like how
lonely my son is you know I wouldn't we
grew up and let's just like this
happened door knock quarantine it'd be
great you know maybe we got freaking
play and we can you know hang out with
other people besides ourselves but it's
just him and so you know I really wish I
had more kids don't hope is David the
reason you changed your mind is he the
person who made that shift happen in you
well of chocolate the chocolate might
have been you know the person who egged
that on but you know I think after the
whole divorce I just felt like I didn't
want your Logan to be by himself you
know like we got together when we were
young with me my sisters and talked
about our parents behind their backs he
needs somebody to do that with and
bounce ideas off and so yeah has
quarantine tested your relationship with
David at all or made it stronger I think
one team is just in everyone's
relationship I've gotten extremely petty
about cleaning the kitchen who did it
last yes that's the part you know one
dish a break up this up oh right but you
know we really have gotten closer to be
honest we've had a chance to talk about
things that we wouldn't normally have
time to talk about and see things that
we normally wouldn't see because we
haven't spent this much time together
and
have to say he's not just chocolate he's
a great guy all right okay see those
hands there's not a ring on them yet is
there no this must be in the air because
everyone has been asking me you know
come on come on log bring it on down
with a cure all right we gotta give him
a little nudge and help him out a little
bit you know Dave's been single for
forever he's never been married and so
far you know him to find love you know
he's you know creepy crawling but he's
better area do you think a quarantine
proposal could happen it could I mean I
wouldn't say that yeah that would be my
ideal but I'll take whatever get you
know you can actually walk me around the
corner that's it then okay yeah how is
the family how are your sisters doing is
anybody driving you nuts and quarantine
like you're hearing from them every day
yes everyone's driving each other no I
don't know we get together and zoom and
FaceTime all the time and that's been
pretty fun I haven't seen my mom in
three months and that's been really
really tough you know um so yeah we've
been zooming and we really had a really
good time and you know you're getting
closer and talking about things that
don't that needs to be talked about
before we start filming again okay yeah
I was gonna say how has the next season
of Braxton Family Values has been
impacted by this well we're just like
every other show including this one you
know I wasn't finished production with
mutation and definitely wasn't finished
with the Braxton so we get on the
computer we get on the phone and that's
how we do it because this is our new
normal
okay so we're gonna see some quarantine
life stuff I guess in the next season I
miss my family
you know I miss my sisters I can't
really you don't spend a lot of time
with Tony because you know she has lupus
when it's really dangerous for her um so
I've seen her twice and I'm grateful for
that but I don't see them so I look
forward to seeing them however I can and
so I just take that for now which is
such a nice thing to hear because think
back to years ago
where you and your sisters were filming
the show yeah it was not that place
no and as a matter of fact for the past
what four seasons and we haven't been in
that place I just think sometimes
sisters go through things and I think by
the time we start filming we're going
through things and when we're done
shooting we're back to normal so that's
why I'm like I'm hoping that keep our
fingers crossed that the cameras catches
at a time when everything is going great
for us a more fun moment than the
dramatic you know I mean I don't want to
argue anyway anyone but the devil and I
don't want any drama you know I mean I'm
living my best life
I'm eating my weights you know and I'm
having fun with my boyfriend and great
time with my kid and I have absolutely
no worries and I have this amazing show
on vh1 which is a dream job for me a
dream situation and I'm just really
really happy good place and it's the
kind of content we need right now to
take our mind off of everything though I
feel like some people might watch him
like god I miss the salon even more yes
yes we all do but we all look a mess
together
it's quarantine inspiring any new music
it actually has you know I think it's
inspiring all the musicians because you
know we haven't been able to do shows
and you know go to a proper studio and I
feel like everyone is missing that that
spark that I know I thought I am I know
when I released I'm crazy kind of love I
fell in love with music and now I'm over
here like twiddling my thumbs really
missing it like having meetings with the
producers and what is my next sound
gonna be what's my next look gonna be
and I'm just so inspired and so excited
how far away are we from getting and new
songs I know we got crazy kind of love
kind of at the start of all this yes
well I haven't been recording what I
have recorded a few records before
quarantine study so Lucy you're still
not changing your mind about releasing
another full album Luverne a happiness
still the final album no you know I mean
I think at that time I was really going
through a lot you know a lot of people
didn't know that this and I were
breaking up and it wasn't a good time
you know for either of us
individually and then the business
aspect of it all changed because he was
my manager and so it was just like a big
turn-off for me and now that I've fallen
back in love with music it's like I
falling back in love with the whole
situation of it all you know 2020
through awful lot of plans for people is
there anything left on the team our
vision board that you were hoping to
make it happen this year that's maybe
getting pushed to 2021 like I remember
three years ago you still wanted a talk
show you wanted to return to TV in that
way I still do it's still a dream of
mine you know I think that now that a
couple of situations for me have changed
that door is a possibility and I'm
really grateful about that well I hope
you get to walk through that door sooner
rather than later thank you thank you so
much all right I gotta ask you did you
hear from Tony after her you started the
Toni Braxton channel so I'm gonna show
you how to do Toni Braxton you got to
put bass in your throat like mm-hmm okay
like you finna call for burp or
something like you can't finish no
sentence and um you just gotta have that
real deep emotion okay ma'am I
understand nothing you say I'm gonna
kill you babyface so it's so funny
because we love to choose her she's the
hardest person to you know try to sound
like and so I guess that's why she's
Toni Braxton huh cause can't nobody do
she does you do a pretty good Tony
Braxton
standing in the back there singing
behind her listen to it all she ever do
at a my impression yes she does and she
doesn't get it right
ever ever next time you talk to her you
should ask her it's terrible you give me
a little bit of your Tony cuz it brings
me so much joy so low and soft it's so
good all right well thanks for talking
to me today I'm excited for to catch
beautician
premiering Monday right Monday and
Monday at nine o'clock on vh1
[Music]